bonjour et coop est bon jour on vise le
tambour aux auditeurs de martini
première désolé pour ma voix pourquoi
alors tâchera d'y arriver jusqu'au bout
rick qu'en fait vous soutenez emmanuel
macron du mouvement marche ou la
présidentielle française tout d'abord
les socios tour du qui fait quoi au nom
du manuel macron en martinique sont ils
définitivement réglée qui est le
référent mais c'est très clair ça a été
réglé un plusieurs semaines je dirais
même près de moi je suis le référent
d'emmanuel magro martinique
parce qu'il n'y a plus aucun référent
sur la carte de martinique du candidat
mathieu duhamel devient quoi il y à 140
référent dans toute la france mathieu
gamme à une mission on l'a dit il a une
mission de nous aider à récolter les
parrainages c'est ce que nous avons
commencé à faire et il a une mission
également de nous accompagner dans
l'organisation des débats
alors est ce que vous voyez
régulièrement avec les autres élus qui
avaient cosigné l'appel à soutenir le
candidat dans marche comment les choses
s'organisent autour de cette campagne
pour emmanuel macron chez nous aiment
écouter c'est très clair nous avons une
réunion hebdomadaire
nous nous voyons très régulièrement nous
avons commencé un travail de trac thing
d'ailleurs à saint pierre au robert à
sainte-marie et nous continuons pas le
sud cette semaine
est-ce que vos participer aux échanges
au sein du pôle outremer dans marche
présidée par anne bolliet oui nous
sommes dans une démarche de coopération
sur sept dans ce pôle outremer
d'ailleurs il est probable que la
semaine prochaine soit organisé une
série de rencontres avec ce pôle
outremer et également des
visioconférences puisque nous allons
avec nos amis guyanais est guadeloupéen
essayer de nous organiser pour avoir des
d un front commun je dirais et peser
dans ce programme qui doit être présenté
au début du mois de mars on a déjà des
orientations pour ce comité outre-mer
spécifiquement écouté il y à quelques
annonces qui ont été faites
on sait notamment que
le candidat portera des mesures sur la
continuité territoriale
ce qui est important il portera
également des mesures sur le les mesures
spécifiques à l'outre-mer notamment en
lien avec l'antique 349 du traité
européen pour nous permettre notamment
dans la pêche dans l'agriculture de
pouvoir avoir des spécificités la paix
c'est très important parce que vous
savez que en europe ont détruit des
bateaux et c'est ce qui a conduit un peu
à un flux à affaiblir la pêche ici à la
martinique
nous nous souhaitons au contraire que
nous puissions recommencer à construire
des bateaux parce que nous ne sommes pas
dans la même configuration que qu'en
europe il y à ici une ressource que nous
n'exploitons pas peut-être quelque chose
à dire à ce qui concerne ce qui fait
l'actualité du jour
la coop est peut-être des choses à dire
à des propositions à faire ce qui
concerne l'histoire
les commémorations cette reconnaissance
de crimes contre l'humanité pour la
colonisation ici et ailleurs
écoutez là dessus je serais tout à fait
à l'aise
d'abord le candidat macron a commencé sa
campagne en venant dans les outre mer il
est venu en guyane il est venu en
guadeloupe et il est venu ici à la
martinique sans doute que son passage
dans la dans le pays de césaire l'a
inspiré en tout cas je l'espère et je
suis très heureux effectivement que le
candidat et ai dit ceci alors dans un
contexte qui n'est pas le nôtre qu'il
faut aussi le reconnaître c'est le
contexte de l'algérie ce ne serait pas
notre contexte mais enfin nous inspirons
nous espérons simplement qu'ils là qu'il
a appris cette inspiration effectivement
de césaire en tout cas il est il est
complètement à l'eau sans paraphraser
mais il est complètement en lien avec le
discours sur le colonialisme leu leu leu
leu leu
l'oni à liz may tune est une entreprise
de désunion des illuminations 7,7
c'est un crime et le reconnaît et j'en
suis très heureux ce que françois fillon
qualifie quand même d'éternel rapportant
sida de bissy pour quelqu'un qui prétend
à la présidence de la république
écoutez c'est un certain discours
hypocrite il faut qu'à un moment donné
la france reconnaisse de manière lucide
que ben oui que la colonisation si pour
certains elle a apporté tout cas pour
nous est là c'était une entreprise de
déminage de déshumanisation 6000 asie
elle c'est un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont été sorties de leur
pays
c'est des gens qu'on a forcés à
travailler cdd des richesses qui ont été
pillés donc il faut que la france
l'assument
vous attendez voir une telle éruption de
ce thème à ce niveau de la campagne
écoutez non parce que je savais que le
candidat évidemment aléas en algérie je
savais que c'était un voyage qui prouve
qu'ils pouvaient comporter notamment ce
thème mais je ne je ne pensais pas qu'il
aurait fait preuve de courage tel qu'il
a fait preuve de courage les sondages
eric opt sondages donnent emmanuel
macron en deuxième position à l'issue du
premier tour vous l'avez dit très
bientôt le 2 mars plus exactement c'est
la date à laquelle il détaillera et
chiffrera son programme sur quel thème
selon vous doit-il assisté pour séduire
davantage d'électeurs sur le thème de la
valeur travail alors que benoît hamon
lui préconise le revenu universel
du coup tous les mois pour moi il ya
deux thèmes qui sont fondamentaux le
premier c'est la jeunesse
le premier c'est l'éducation et
notamment pour nous en martinique
je pense que il faut qu'ils appuient sur
l'éducation de manière à ce que nos
jeunes puissent trouver une voie on voit
bien que le chômage
endémique auxquels nous devons faire
face est liée aussi à des problèmes de
formation est évidemment le deuxième
c'est le travail la valeur travail sur
laquelle il a fondé toute sa campagne
fondamentale selon moi d'abord il
reconnaît que le travail est notamment
que l'entreprise était une haie et est
une est une chose extrêmement importante
et il reconnaît par là même que c'est un
lieu de réalisation de l'humain et pour
moi c'est fondamental problématique
c'est en va à contre a choisi d'aller se
former ailleurs le candidat hamon
propose un revenu universel et ses ponts
- nier le rôle fondamental du travail
et ça pour moi c'était une chose
extrêmement importante
alors il ya deux choses qu'on peut
reprocher aux candidats amont et c'est
pour ça que avec mes camarades du du du
ppm que son frais de l'ordi notamment et
et dany chômé nous avons choisi de
soutenir ce candidat parce que d'abord
c'est un progressiste et le montre
aujourd'hui quand il prend cette
position sur le colonialisme et puis
j'étais un progressisme et qui transite
qui transitent qu'il qui transcende de
pardon la droite et la gauche il
il prend une position très claire aussi
par rapport au cannabis il dit non à la
dépénalisation et c'est fondamental
alors là on nous a menti nique vous
l'avez lyrique opéra le ppm n'a pas
vraiment digéré de voir plusieurs de ses
membres cosigné l'appel
une procédure est en cours au niveau du
réservoir de traînel des positions des
auditions ont débuté premier radar
c'était daniel chomet me semble lundi
dernier avez-vous vous déjà été reçus
par les instances progressistes n'ont
écouté
effectivement ce qu'on peut noter c'est
que d'abord c'est pas d'une procédure de
disciplinaire comme certains ont bien
voulu
alors vous ayez un terreau de détourner
d'éventuelles sanctions on est dans une
dans une phase d'écouté nous nous sommes
très contents ça nous permet ça nous a
permis notamment à un dernier show mais
de de s'expliquer j'en suis très heureux
pour ma part je skie vraisemblablement
reçu également frais de l'ordi nous
également moi ce que je ce que je peux
dire d'abord c'est que je suis un
militant du parti progressiste
martiniquais
je suis un sept militants je suis pas je
suis pas la direction de ce parti
mais quand on est un militant et que on
reste un peu en recul et on constate que
et bien il ya des ya déjà des il ya déjà
des il ya des choses qui sont il ya du
progressisme à droite à gauche
quand moi je suis pas candidat juge pas
je ne soutiens pas nicolas sarkozy je
n'ai jamais soutenu
mais quand nicolas sarkozy lance les
grenelle de l'environnement est ce que
c'est de droite ou de gauche
quand comment elle s'appelle madame
d'ulysse dit qu'elle est pour
l'autonomie constitutionnelle
c'est ni de droite ni de gauche et
l'alliance du ppm avec jenny dulys nous
paraît tout à fait un lien avec nos
valeurs vous redoutiez d'être exclu du
ppm non je ne redoute rien vous savez je
suis militant c'est tout merci eric à
coop est on est arrivé jusqu'au bout
malgré nos maux de gorge les récifs
merci d'abritel si haut qu'on se
présente encore nous excuse aux
auditeurs pour la qualité de nos voix ce
matin votre journée merci
[Musique]